the univ on students gives me tremendous
hope I see an enormous range of talent
and opportunity in the students that
pass through my courses and through the
church and through the other settings in
which I meet young people here in across
the country I have tremendous hope in
the rising generation I believe in them
I believe not only are they in terms of
the admission statistics vatta then
their parents I believe that they are
less capable of being seduced by the
talents and the treasures of this world
that they have a higher standard at what
they want and what they feel they
deserve and what the world requires I
look to them to produce in some sense
this ideal world their parents have had
their chance and they squandered it
there's not much there that we had it
seems to me but in these young kids that
we produce regularly each year out of
colleges like this one I believe there
is the world's best jobs the world's
best hope that gives me cause for
encouraging